Good evening friends, welcome to the DNews
Netflix Screening Room, I'm Trace.
This week I popped into Netflix on my iPad
and Chomecasted to a TV at work to watch The
Act of Killing, which is nominated for an
Oscar this year.
If you'd like to watch this movie, and I'd
highly recommend it -- you can pick up Netflix
for yourself FREE for a month by going to
Netflix.com/dnews and signing up.
You could be streaming TV and movies to all
your devices in no time!
Plus, it helps support us here at DNews.
20th century Indonesia was a rough place.
There were political battles between the right
and left wings, with the right finally coming
together and killing thousands of communists.
The Act of Killing follows the stories of
some of the top death-squad leaders and allows
them a forum to relive their glory days.
It's very difficult to watch them joking about
how they killed people, explaining why the
used this method or that -- For example: they
preferred to strangle people with wire, because
beating them to death was too slow and the
blood would make the room smell.
It was a simple, logical decision for them,
but a horrendous one for humankind.
Psychotherapists and neurologists identify
the traits of a psychopath as having superficial
charm, lack of remorse, and an impersonal
sex life, whereas sociopaths have a lack of
empathy -- or the inability to understand
the emotional responses of others.
The men featured by the documentary likely
would fall into BOTH of these.
These murderers lied to the public, and killed
the communist sympathizers for trumped-up
offenses, or sometimes just for associating
with the wrong people.
A reasonable person would ask, how could they
be so inhumane?
A study in the journal Brain, researched the
ability of psychopaths to experience empathy
and found their brains were able to flip a
switch turn it on or off.
This study suggests these men can still EXPERIENCE
or UNDERSTAND empathy and morality the same
as anyone else, but may have simply flipped
it off.
Watching the movie, you see some shadows of
their inner torture, but only with some of
them.
These death-squad leaders describe what they've
done with smiles on their faces the way you
or I would describe a weekend away with friends.
Their nostalgia and camaraderie is both banal
and shocking.
They relive these terrible experiences with
laughter, punctuated by discussions of politics,
morality, and ethics.
Strangely, as a group their discussions seem
more apologetic, but alone their true feelings
range from tortured to defiant.
It's really jaw-dropping.
The scene where former death-squad leader
Anwar Congo describes how he killed people
by strangling them with wire is super crazy.
He laughs while demonstrating the method by
wrapping a wire around a pole, and then his
friends neck.
Then he leans away pulling the wire taut and
looks at the camera with a smile.
Moments later, his face pulls as he recalls
the numbing of these painful memories with
alcohol, drugs and sex.
You want to hate him and what he did in the
name of politics and hatred, but you also
see him as an old man with regrets.
It's an emotional ride, for sure.
I'd highly recommend this powerful film, but
you're probably gonna need a hug after.
If you have Netflix, check out 'The Act of
Killing' and leave your review in the comments!
If you don't have it yet, visit netflix.com/dnews
and sign up for that free month of streaming
and help support us here at DNews!
Thanks for watching, make sure you subscribe.
Next Screening Room we're going to do a happy
one, I promise!